Hey hey guys good morning look at this
guy huh come on
good morning good morning hubby all
right so I am already all except for the
makeup but I'm all ready to go to JK
party today is the first time I think
I'm bringing you guys to take a party I
don't think I've ever blogged there
never take them to work I know I never
did cuz I'm worried about work I don't
want to worry about working men work I
don't know that's true I think double
work yeah so yeah but today I'm gonna be
bringing you guys and I'm gonna be
vlogging on my phone Casey will be
vlogging as well so you'll get to see
both of our perspectives for today I
gotta go now I'm running late alright I
just got in your school yeah hello so
we're finishing up our makeup right now
cuz I couldn't finish it at home so
doing that and then we're gonna begin
take a partay so it's dig your party day
yeah how do you feel I feel great
where's one of the years the first one
of you being a daddy - oh yeah cuz he
got sick right now
so I had to do the entire night shift
last night pretty tired I woke up like
three times you doing yeah
we're back take your party hi job how
was your great it was awesome I was
shopping I get you you never wear DS I
know I'm like the same way now so I can
thank you you're excited that number
back on JK party and we also have a
million subscribers now isn't that oh
and it's gonna take us nine months to
get our subscriber oh man I know it's so
exciting I'm kissing all the tweets and
congratulations and everything it's all
happening 2018 ticket party shoot first
of the year
[Applause]
we're trying to aim to grow a lot bigger
force 2018 and because of that bar will
explain what we can do to grow so we
have we have a meeting for this year in
kind of a direction we want to go it
usually on jacob party days we film like
four five sometimes six videos each day
since we film once every other week so
we can have enough videos to upload and
always give you guys content today we've
already up to this point we've already
filmed two videos and I think it's
lunchtime so I'm just waiting for food
and I am just trying to wake up it since
this morning I've been so sleepy I
already drink coffee and everything but
I feel like the fact that it's gloomy
today is just not helpful do you guys
ever feel like that where is just so
gloomy you just feel so tired and so
blah you're kind of really dragging out
the day that's kind of mean today so not
a good thing especially when we're
filming JK partying that's such a
high-energy type of videos that we do
just finish eating we're just hanging
out now everyone's having conversations
I'm just sitting on this louisvil face
looking for tons cherries Craig's we
have every time I see it I'm like this
is so tacky it's so funny but yeah so
what are you doing and I'm eating chips
are expired why they're expired like
guess how long they've been expired for
I don't tell me like 2016 or something
no it's at least 2017 oh my god it's
been July that's like we went to Paris
and said yeah what's so good now they
say like expiration dates are all like
yeah you're just like you kind of go by
that but not really it's not like a for
sure set like date you can actually go
past it but apparently some chips are
good pass
how many months six months seven eight
months as weird because it says no
artificial flavors or preservatives no
there's no yeah probably that's all all
right so I'm chilling at home and
everyone's at the office shooting JK
party the recording and they I guess
they're taking a break because they're
now they're spying on me what are you
guys doing gotcha okay bye all right so
while TIFF is that Jacob party I'm
usually just at home by myself
editing and writing gets kind of boring
it's kind of money
so I also take the opportunity to plan
for dinner I end up cooking just because
it's so fun to cook for me cooking is a
very much so a stress reliever usually
days like Tuesdays and Thursdays where
TIFF goes out and she films I spend that
time to prepare dinner to have something
hot and ready by the time I need to go
pick up Isaac from school and by the
time TIFF comes back home from work and
today I'm gonna be making something for
the first time I've never actually made
this dish before every time we go to
France it's one of those like obligatory
dishes you just have to get and eat and
I'm pulling the specific recipe from
this book that I received for Christmas
eat what you watch a cookbook for movie
lovers it's written by the guy that runs
the channel binging with babish and he
made a book about cooking foods that you
see in movies and I receive this book as
a gift for Christmas from Barton Gio
it's very thoughtful thank you farting
Gio they know that I love to cook and
they know I love movies and so this is
like literally the most like well
thought out Christmas gifts that I've
received in a long time
now who remembers elf in this mmm
ratatouille just like in the movie oh
cool Poe fiction with its Hawaiian
burger mm-hmm this is a tasty burger
inglourious basterds oh this is one of
those where when you watch this movie
you're gonna be craving that
the Viennese strudel that's what it's
called huh
and I know that me and Bart always
called it the Hans Landa with the way
Christoph Waltz eats that strudel it is
anyways back to what I'm actually making
today it is the quintessential Biff
boogie gnome it's from the movie Julie
and Julia which I've never seen before
but I just saw this and I'm like I'm
sold I want to eat that tonight
unfortunately the only down part to this
recipe is the fact that it takes so much
ingredients to make let's see if it
compares to the stuff in France
[Music]
all right so after filming I came here
to Gio's my cutie I've been playing in
this whole timing so he's gotten so much
bigger I just can't believe that you're
so big tiger
he didn't cry with you he cries with
Bart's mom oh he does oh I feel special
Hey look at you over there look over
here dude you gotten so big the last
time I saw you and then since I didn't
get a chance to see taiko before we went
out to Dallas that it wasn't able to
give him his little gift here and so I
got him this little bug it's a touch of
feel book you like it oh are you okay
yeah yeah get out of my face mama okay
sorry
no you like it cutie pie
uh he's already looking at the book no
not in the room anymore not he was
holding it to saved your life
open it open it oh my god Oh cute
ready go show show theater security way
so precious oh my goodness and then I
was telling Gio earlier to I was like oh
my gosh I need to go see Tai Chi like
I'm having taiko withdraws and every
time I see him he's growing bigger and
bigger and I'm like I'm missing out I
can't miss any milestone and then do is
telling me that Tycho's rolling over
I know you're gay ready to show
everybody your show everybody huh good
job
take that hey you couldn't let me have
QT gay crawling now look good but I feel
anything soon like yeah it's so funny
cuz I try remembering like what it was
like raising eyes because I pretty much
like yeah his dad was there but honestly
I pretty much did like 95% of everything
when Isaac was a baby and so yeah like
you'll be asking me like man how did you
do it and I try to remember like how did
I do it I don't know how that I don't
remember at all cuz that Bart's help and
I'm like oh he's don't need more help
and at my mom's help and I'm still like
oh oh my god I didn't let him do it yeah
babies are a handful that's why I don't
exactly remember what it was like but I
do remember feeling like man this is
overwhelming heartache up you entered
the conversation too you're like yeah I
know I'm a handful I know what the f but
yeah that's why I think about I'm like
oh yeah I want to take my time with it
like one yeah take your time for sure
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right the table is set we are about
to eat dinner wait for Tiffa come home I
hear she's at Bart's house playing with
tyka she ought to make her own baby so
she could play here at home all right
come home now I think I spent about 3
hours that part in Gio's place just
playing with Thai cookies he's so cute I
could just never get enough in him but
now I'm home and I get to play with my
cuties because I have to I have two kids
you know how became a kid yeah yeah
let's see what they're up to
hey guys hello ho I heard you Hey both
vlogging blood ception you have the
actual amount Paris they give you this
camera but you chose see I know I
honestly like vlogging with the phone
better right I was just like smaller and
portable and like not like just more
discreet I guess what you're hauling
that thing around I can't fit that in my
purse and you lady my baby how was your
day at school okay I'm gonna turn this
one off so you just focus on it yeah I
love coming home and like the whole
dinner is just and for once it's not
Chinese food or anything Asian you've
got the wine port and everything I know
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but you talk to him in Spanish as he
falls asleep so you can learn some
Spanish I am NOT gonna spend all night
what happened was I had a burp stuck in
my throat so like
[Music]